hier ich sehe einen namen hier ganz
hinten ein anderer seite hinten so
unsere drei aufgaben nein wo lebst du
denn hin
ich sehe dich gar nicht halt hier hinten
bist du blind hier oder hier im
werksteam destatis waren activator 8ku
sollen in den staat aktivieren
die chance dass die stadt deraa ja da
müssen wir drauf drücken
ich hab aufgeklebt watchers noch mal
theater bis dahin ist starter bmi dass
so ein komisches licht
ja ich hab's database hinter mir
wie lange oder sollten wir zum 1
barca das b-team laserstrahl gegangen
und wieder zum 1
gesagt mach du mal von anderen seite
andere seite genau da dort einfach alle
alle schalter irgendwie glaub mir gut
vorstellen brd ich kann das nicht leben
weil da die rüstung fondsmanager
komplett herzlich sametime okay ich
mache ich drücke ich hab's wieder
zombies ja krass viele ich werde dich
auf hart kommt man mehr zombies sind ja
nur stärker gerüstet welches die tür
dann einfach offen oder wie glaube ich
aber es irgendwie cool das ist alles so
ohne irgendwelche motto funktioniert die
man sich installieren muss das heft ich
endlich das heft ich sowas zu bauen
vor allem hat der vor vier wochen als
letzter raus großer teil der innerhalb
von drei wochen so eine geile web hier
wieder aufgebaut wird dafür ein jahr
brauchen und habt ihr nicht hingekriegt
warte mal ganz kurz warten noch ganz
kurz muss man kurz mich auf heilen auf
euch auch so hast schon gedrückt
egal wo in der höhe der höhe
hallo bei mir kommt gar kein gegner das
sind ist der ibm sametime okay bis 2 b
ich musste erst mal ein paar zombies
kuscheln
die ganze zeit ach so ich dachte okay
doch gedrückt wird sind bei mir wieder
ganz viele
wir sind richtig viele so richtig
mehrheit alle die hast du nicht okay
wochen sonst halten sich mit waffen auf
mich losgehen sondern noch nur ein gas
can generate abläuft zum letzten mal die
türen offen
das ist hinter wen auch immer zu dir
ich lese schon mal vorne ist bei metro
people to get the lovers hier ich deinen
namen hier ganz hinten ein anderer seite
hinten so unsere drei aufgaben nein wo
lebst du denn hin hätte ich gar nicht
halter hier hinten schon gut bist du
blind hinter dir hinter dir du sollst
dich zum laserstrahl gehen altert
bisexuelle klügste war englisch sowie
sollen den industriellen sektor finden
sie den bereich wir soll den generator
wieder slicks und wir sollen einen weg
durch das nuklear power play finden
ja ich würde sagen kraus 28 sogar durch
die metro es hätte mich das ein bisschen
an meinvz
diese klein sind echt nervig richtig
nervig kommt jemand dann kommen so
riesen skelette halter von widgets
beleidigt auch schon wieder nicht die
kleinen sind richtig aggressive die
sinnvoll schlimm eigentlich nervös und
kleine schätze ok ich erst mal ganz kurz
was ich schreibe auch links rum
ich will mich erst mal eigentlich ganz
kurz regieren
ich habe aber auch keine pfeile sind das
jetzt aber kommt ein kleiner blödmann
das auf das sonst gleich mit schwert
oder so ich muss kurz leben auf heilen
versucht ihn mit 12
hast du überhaupt so welche posten
geholt was für passions diese porsche
ich habe kohle
es geht mir gut ich habe keine pfeile
mehreres total bitter war das vergifte
96 vor den clubs mit denen zu tun
dies bot dieser klein warst warst für
leute ja ich denke das liegt am pazifik
doch dieser teil geräusche vielleicht
sind es einfach netter zombies und
textur also wo kann ich nicht sagen ja
dann müssen die mobs anders programmiert
sein
vielleicht ist es auch in solch eine
portion adrenalin shop was das denn es
ist ein adrenalin shop auch so
geschwindigkeit
ja krass dass man einfach dadurch laufen
wird ich bin so schnell dass man sich
über wollte ich jetzt mal in mich
kriegst du nie
ich denke dass diese blöden teilen fest
all das ist ein riesen explosion gewesen
da sind böse creeper okay ein explodiert
alle sind tot dank handelt es gibt nur
einen weg da brauchst nicht wir denken
aber ich weiß nicht gerade aus wie
gerade aus geht's ja aber da ging es
nicht mehr auf lang ich schau doch mal
ganz kurz was da war
die spender mal richtig eklig aus hast
du [ __ ] mit ein paar sich davon
aber nicht schnell
ja ich laufe einfach nur von den wegfall
hier gleich irgendwo runter jetzt ein
abfluss einfach ich glaube dass auch den
abfluss runter ja so klein ich glaube
dass zur u bahn schacht durch auch wir
bräuchten wirklich am besten solche
fakten
so warte ich lass das mal ganz kurz
leben auf das
panda machten am norderstedter so ein
kleiner ich sehe den gar nicht in der
dunkelheit bist du so können wir jetzt
lange raus ja gute idee geht nicht
wahrscheinlich muss aufpassen shift auf
welcher ua ja das ist doch welche ganz
schön viele weg weg weg weg weg wie alle
tot
ich hab' ich gerückt so viele
roth
boulder was nicht schnell wenn ich mit
dieser geschwindigkeit links anders
sprich das eigentlich noch 7 sekunden
das muss ausnutzen
nein ich bin wieder langsam jetzt raus
es geht
ich glaube ich sehe da ganz hinten so
eine art ausgang und jetzt feine unsere
kreml teil darunter wird das hier als
ein stützen das ist ja gar kein leben
ist es richtig geil aber es lohnt sich
warteraum ist fertig stadtplan jetzt
eine trank der heilung drin ist ja der
reingetan hochgehen debattiert da geht
es doch oder kommen wir ganz ganz viele
zombies alter krass viele kadaver selber
beschriften ab sofort gesehen meine sind
jetzt ich höre dass gott die haben das
sind was sind das denn für welche die
sprinten den auf jeden fall froh dass er
wieder draußen sind wie ich zurück nach
ich mach das schon sehr nett von dir
konny reimann
so etwas eine kiste mit einem change
wort es besser ich schaue mir alles
sieht aus wie eine kettensäge
ok ich glaube dass das james ward
ausgleich von baden-baden wirklich
aussieht wieso links waren netzteil
diese diese leitung wieder oben drüber
sind die idee züge mit elektrizität
versorgt
ich habe keine feinde
was ändert sich das ja ich hoffe nur
dass die bälle jetzt mal jemand vorbei
ist weil ich sehe ihr einfach überall
nur noch zombie und ich hab keinen plan
wo wir hingehen soll jetzt richtig ab ja
bei mir auch auch woran gefallen